all right Yellow Jackets fans episode 7
is a wonderful reunion of the yellow
jackets but that doesn't mean the claws
ain't coming out because right now
Shauna is Yellow Jackets Mike Tyson
throwing some Haymakers and eating ears
okay anyways welcome back to heavy
spoilers your home for spoilers that are
heavy and in this video we're going to
be discussing everything in yellow
jackets episode 7 full on story
breakdown callback strange references
and parallels and some theories that
actually I'm betting are actually
correct so if you enjoy this video
hitting that like button is much
appreciated and helps the channel and
subscribe to heavy spoilers to stay up
to date on all of our Yellow Jackets
coverage with all of that out of the way
thank you so much for clicking this I'm
your host Jared now let's get into
Yellowjackets episode 7. alright so this
episode is predominantly based at
lottie's compound as a sort of reunion
and I think the most shocking part of
this whole season is that it's only been
a week yeah like seven days that's it
but everyone yeah here has their own
kind of quirks Natalie has fully been
draped in purple succumbing to lottie's
Wellness Misty has only been there for
24 hours and has also succumbed taking
on the role of gathering the Newcomer's
possessions there's some weird looks
amongst Ty when Natalie mentions walls
being up while also looking at van so
that's kind of our first hint hint that
there's still feelings for her while
Lottie seems to give a skittish look
when Natalie brings up dark
got some really
place so again hinting that she may know
more than she's letting on another thing
about Lottie is that the others have
brought up multiple times that they
thought she was in Switzerland which you
know Lottie does confirm but that was
decades ago now apparently going to
Switzerland can be a euphemism for
ending your own life so I'm wondering if
the writers here are cleverly adding
some more subtext to lottie's character
which explains further why she wanted to
stop Natalie from putting a rifle in her
mouth anyway most of this episode is the
core Yellowjackets each participating in
a different therapy to kind of help with
past trauma things that they've kind of
buried down and so forth I'm curious if
Lottie purposely kind of rigged this
though because each pick something
that's oddly catered to their specific
character with Shauna's therapy being
self-care Misty's guidance taisa's
renewal and vans is forage of course
each is uh you know like I said
personally craft for each of them so
Sean honest therapy is self-care and
yeah this ain't no spa day massage
treatment I'm loving this instead Shauna
is tasked with taking care of a baby
goat named Bruce now this is a clever
way of her to deal with the trauma of
losing her baby boy back in the
wilderness because not only is this a
baby goat but baby goats are typically
called a kid and it's male which was
like her lost baby so her and watching
this little guy symbolizes the
opportunity she was robbed of all of
those years ago and caused her to kind
of keep Cali way closer hover more than
allowing Cali to experience her life
without this constant oversight of you
can't do this you can't do that the
interesting thing is how quickly Shauna
jumps to the conclusion of thinking that
they want her to Slit the goat's throat
again this is supposed to be self-care
so why the heck does she think this well
it's because that Wilderness DNA is
baked into her she did something similar
to the rabbit from season one and not to
mention the deer and pit girl from
season one so I think subtly self-care
for Shauna has been a kind of form of
killing because of the anger and rage
she had built up in the wilderness and
then stuffed all the way down but it's
always been there like it's always there
metaphorically finally dealing with her
baby's death is the real self-care here
I find it gives a person Clarity to have
to
care for something so innocent
not crying about the goat
there's a couple of interesting things
that pop up with Misty and Shauna are
looking for the baby goat all of which
mirrors Misty and the others looking for
Crystal back in the wilderness but Misty
bringing up low calorie counts and
hallucinations this can't be coincidence
have fun I have some bait oh I've been
kind of hoarding food in case they
decide to enforce calorie restriction to
induce out of body experiences I think
my blood sugar can't handle that okay
this could be an in your face line
explaining some of the weird stuff that
has been happening back in the
wilderness again giving a scientific
explanation to this otherwise
Supernatural elements that we've seen
Shauna and Lottie seem to be sharing the
same kind of sentiments about present
day and whether or not things are real
Shauna questioning Cali while Lottie has
been seen to question the reality of the
Wilderness and what has happened so we
should kind of maybe keep a pin in this
and see where this whole idea of what's
real and what's not comes up again or
not me Misty's therapy was guidance and
leading to her confronting her problems
with the sensory deprivation chamber
basically Misty takes on the role of 11
from stranger things and is treated to a
delicious nod from Twin Peaks with the
black outfit against the red curtain
similar to that of the Black Lodge this
could have been something Misty watched
as a child as well but yeah her sh gets
bananas like you need some sports
enhancers for this whole section as it's
a musical number from Walter and her
bird Caligula honestly did this show
jump the shark at this point absolutely
not do I need more of this fever dream
Insanity absolutely 100 percent the
whole point of this is Misty finding a
bit more of that self-confidence that
she's severely lacking learning that
Caligula was named after the Roman
Emperor is something that we mentioned
back in episode one if you didn't know
this dude was completely unhinged in
some history even say that he was
actually insane Caligula is played by
John Cameron Mitchell which is a great
nod to Misty's obsession with musicals
because he wrote and directed Hedwig And
The Angry itch which was based on a 1998
stage musical by the same name anyway
through this Misty questions whether or
not she's desperate for love and in fact
is a murder but yeah at the end of this
she is not rehabilitated at all because
Caligula twists things a bit basically
persuading Misty that she's actually a
closer and that's a good thing and she's
not desperate for love even though the
first thing she does after getting out
of the chamber is run to the phone and
call Walter hence being desperate for
love I'm gonna hang up
[Laughter]
swear I can change her just give me some
time in the voicemail message she admits
Walter was right about the thing I'm
guessing the whole Adam Martin situation
so I wonder if Walter is the one who
finds the remains at the end of this
episode it would then connect him back
into the fold to be honest a couple
other things of note is the Garfield
phone I I love it I mean it doesn't have
any significance I just I just wanted to
talk about it but the newspaper on
Caligula's vanity shows what looks like
a picture of the Yellowjackets team
along with an article mentioning the
blizzard of 1996 the same year that they
were stuck in the wilderness so just
some kind of neat notes here or there
but the biggest thing is the musical
phone conversation between Walter and
Misty
[Applause]
yeah this is Morse code I didn't pick it
up on the first time but when you break
down the code it states I love you which
isn't a big surprise because of the
heart graphic and the way that Misty
reacts but a fun little thing if uh you
know not everyone probably picked up
taisa and vans therapy sessions pale in
comparison to the wacky musical number
of misties but ties does have a bit of a
thing that may play into honestly it
might play into a bigger thing down the
road in future Seasons or the next
couple episodes with hers being renewal
now painting the cabin doesn't mean he
even Ty knows this by brushing swears
and drawing a happy face so we can
ignore that but the renewal idea is
supposed to be her repairing the
sleepwalking Persona she doesn't know
why but Lottie reassures her it's
because that side of her has wisdom
wisdom of the Wilderness or potentially
something else but she needs to
essentially allow for a symbiotic
relationship with it once again rather
than suppressing it does Lottie have
nefarious purposes and maybe tricking
her into allowing it to come back maybe
honestly I could see it happening so I
think we'll have to you know again keep
a note on this and see how this plays
out in the future a few episodes Vans
therapy session was forage which
basically turns into her drinking her
pain away when taisa finds her now we
know that the two have had a past
there's even been a kind of what if
Shoulda Coulda would have Vibe between
the two ever since they met in this
season both Tai taking off her wedding
ring and saying I can't believe I'm here
again this is her referring to being
back with band once again and smooching
with her looks to bring out the other
persona of ties as she becomes more
aggressive with the kissing the big
reveal is Van having cancer only having
a few months to live we had theorized
that the medicine back a handful of
episodes may be hers and that's the case
uh now I don't know how we missed this
but some of the bills in the waste
basket in that previous episode seem to
be from a medical facility so yeah she's
she's only got a few months to live now
this cancer reveal May tie into the
conversation she and Ty had back in the
Wilderness at the start of this episode
with Van questioning why she is still
alive like like what was her purpose
here so it seems far too coincidental
for her to question this all the way
back then only to be diagnosed with
cancer later on I think this further
explains why she's been living in the
past with the video store and Nostalgia
she doesn't have a future so the past is
pretty much all that she has left as
lottie's therapy she is talking to her
fill-in therapist once again and we
gotta chalk this one up as a win
three-pointer nothing but net because
last week we theorized that the
therapist was all in lottie's mind and
is finally revealed at the end of this
session the same color of clothing gave
this one away and the reason Lottie is
spiraling a bit is because of her she
probably isn't taking her medicine again
therefore seeing this other therapist if
I remember correctly her her followers
aren't permitted to do so so maybe maybe
she actually is following that and has
stopped herself the therapist urging her
to reach back into that Primal Freedom
that she had in the wilderness the time
she was essentially at her most free
meaning Lottie is going to be seen a
whole lot of more weird in these coming
episodes but two things about this
really jump out one is Lottie seeing the
antler Queen once again making us think
that she is in fact what carries this
title or she carried this in the
wilderness both her seeing it from a
third person view and being scared of
this site I'm not fully convinced that
Lottie was the one to hold this title we
have a theory a little bit later on but
uh yeah just just wait but another thing
I I'm I'm convinced that this other
therapist has been with Lottie or in her
mind all the way back at the start of
this season when we first see her in the
mental facility the roommate of hers
looks similar to this grown-up therapist
again it's played by a different actress
but they look similar and there's just
it to me it connects and it makes sense
that this other voice had been present
with her for years and it's only now
coming back with her stopping her meds
now I don't let me know in the comments
if I'm off my rocker and I'm digging way
too deep into this one anyway when they
all come together for their reunion at
the end of this episode it's like one
big happy team again and again with any
kind of reunion we're mostly focused on
the good rather than the bad with Lottie
suggesting that many of them probably
don't remember everything clearly
because of the brain going into panic
mode in the wilderness and certain
memories are hiding for example The Rage
of Shauna we can see at the very end of
this episode was brought forth when
adult Shauna went to get her van back
from the chop shop owner the rage-filled
memories were there and this is why she
didn't know why it felt so good anyway
free by Florence and the Machine plays
which is a song about anxiety and how to
process it much like the women have in
this episode let alone sense the
Wilderness so the sharing circle is them
dealing with their current things until
more of the booze flows snow begins to
fall and they celebrate by running
outside this ending bit in present day
mirrors that of the Wilderness as
Lightning Crashes by live or or live
plays the music video of this is about
life rebirth grief but celebration as in
present day all of the yellow jackets
are almost rebirthed there's a renewal
to them yipping like wild dogs dancing
drinking around the fire pit seeing that
snow is something happy and joyous
rather than that of a nightmare and bad
Omen back in the past back in the
wilderness Shauna is dealing with the
grief and now Rage of the loss of her
baby I guess if you didn't notice but
Shauna is currently going through the
five stages of grief last week ended
with her in denial that the baby was
stillborn and that it was actually still
alive but now this episode is clearly
rage as she beats the piss out of Lottie
allowing that rage to manifest into
potentially something greater I don't
think we can show any of this but yeah
Lottie by the end of this episode is
basically Balboa at the end of any Rocky
movie and believes that this is not only
good for Shauna but also good for the
Wilderness so with this following the
five stages of grief for Shauna next
week is no doubt going to be ending with
bargaining in some manner meaning that
the group will be split on something and
maybe have to make a deal with the
Wilderness because according to the
episode 8 teaser the deck of cards comes
into play like we had theorized a couple
episodes ago and this may be the way
that we begin to choose who is
sacrificed and who isn't again Lottie
mentioned the Wilderness doesn't make
deals like one for you one for me but
rather they need food and uh yeah the
the girls and Coach Scott at Hobby
Travis they're all food the most
interesting storyline to me was coach
Scott this week obviously his mental
state is at an ATL and his Escapist
memories of Paul seem to be coming to an
end which means it's a harsh reality of
his current situation that he needs to
face as seen by The increased amounts of
static in this scene it's it's almost
like his memories are being overwritten
much like a VHS tape when multiple
things have been recorded and
re-recorded over it I think some of the
subtext here is that he didn't want the
world to know that he was gay which is
why Paul says that he's not ready or
welcome here anymore but also combined
with the way that Misty berates him
later when he's on the cliff obviously
coach Scott is is wanting to end his
life he shaves his face because he wants
to look his best if and when Rescuers
find his body but also this week's show
description which who wouldn't guest
oddly hints at his unaliving Tendencies
so this is by far the most bizarre
reference of this show so far but
episode 7's description says coach Scott
does a great Carl Havoc impression
and if you didn't know who Carl Havoc is
don't worry because this is a character
from the sketch comedy show I think you
should leave with Tim Robinson basically
he's supposed to do this undercover
hidden camera bit but breaks down that
he doesn't want to live anymore I don't
want to be around anymore
I don't know so yeah obviously shown at
the Cliff's Edge as well but coach Scott
willingly doesn't want to be there or
Alive anymore and according to the weird
hidden frames from like episode two or
three it looks like his days are deftly
numbered also it's a bit odd that the
framing of the antlers are are perfect
on his head when he yells for Paul
outside of the cabin so like hint hint
maybe maybe he's next because Misty
talks about his delicious rump roast
again and I'm not gonna lie I never
thought we'd be able to use this clip
again I'd like to put some barbecue
sauce on that button again
but I think that there is more to this
Cliff scene than meets the eye just just
a lot of the camera angles movements
transitions they feel off like when
Misty is searching for Crystal by the
way where where the heck did her body go
we we got to figure that one out but
right before she confronts coach Scott
the slow zoom out almost sounds like a
camera shutter and some sort of alarm
faintly mixed in with the background
music
so maybe someone is in fact watching
them like cabin in the wood style but
the big question is why the other thing
that stood out to me were the roots of
the tree to the left side of the screen
these look oddly similar to the drawing
that Javi showed to coach Scott a couple
episodes ago maybe we're grasping at
straws here but this specific Cliff spot
has been like a featured multiple times
in episodes the the no eyes man LED evil
tie here a tie-in van also found the
symbol on the tree Crystal fell to her
death here coach Scott wandered out here
the drawing of Javi looks similar to
this location and the weird camera zooms
I had mentioned something is up I'm not
sure what but maybe with Crystal's body
being gone she was taken to the same
place as Javi maybe you know somewhere
underground and is going to come back at
some point like Jesus risen scaring the
bejesus out of everyone specifically
Misty the name Crystal does come from
the Greek word meaning carrier of Christ
and there's been you know a whole bunch
of Greek and and religious symbolism so
if she strolls right back in like
Captain Barbosa I I would not be
surprised the massive Cliffhanger to end
this episode is something that I
appreciate and I am so excited for the
next week because Jeff has done his
homework speaking in code so give him
all the cookies but this begs so many
questions like did Misty completely
botch hiding the body did she give the
remains to someone else to deal with it
did Walter use Clues from his and
Misty's interactions and pinpoint a
potential burial ground honestly my
money is on the last one with it being
revealed that Walter has some sort of uh
yeah I don't know maybe personal
connection to Adam a friend family a
Weekend slam piece I don't know
something but the closing song of dream
girl evil gives us a great understanding
of basically every single main character
in this season revolving around the idea
that despite how someone might seem on
the outside they could still be deeply
flawed in the inside obviously all of
the adult yellow jackets land in this
category but I think this falls on Jeff
too not in a way of past trauma but that
his flaws are in the fact that he's
willing to do anything for Shauna and
potentially maybe spoilers I don't know
at this point for episode 8 looks like
someone may be unaliving from the looks
of the blood splatter in the episode 8
teaser I've seen some theories suggest
that maybe Jeff offs himself leaving a
note explaining his jealousy of the Adam
Affair taking the full blame and
allowing Shauna to be in the clear of
Adam's death it finally feels like
pieces are falling into place this
season and I have a feeling that these
last two episodes yeah I'm sorry to
break it to you it's only nine episodes
rather than ten but all of this these
last two are gonna be nuts all right
getting into theories I'm saying at this
point there are two big ones that are
about to go down first is the Dual
timeline like parallel universe type
stuff uh the way the supernatural
elements have been kind of implemented
combined with the fact that there are so
many Illusions to mirrored images and
events that seem to be memories but are
not the ones that we've seen in the
series as of now like taisa having a
split good and bad personality the
paintings at Vans Natalie seen the plane
all burnt to a crisp with zero survivors
even though a handful of Yellowjackets
did in fact survive to present day and
almost everything involving coach Scott
this season he dreams of a life of love
with Paul witnessing the plane crashing
in a different timeline he's not in and
last week the cabin in his apartment
imagery were smashed together into one
why or how this is happening of course I
don't know this hasn't been revealed yet
but the Wilderness and the Mysterious
markings could be the clue as to why
this is happening to the select group of
yellow jackets it's also a bit odd that
uh a lot and I mean a lot of scenes and
sequences here in season two have
referenced movies TV shows songs and
other events and so forth but there
isn't a ton of evidence to support the
whole Cabin in the Woods meets Truman
Show setup that I kind of uh you know
theorized a couple of times I'm saying
it's possible don't get me wrong it's a
maybe but there's uh there's way too
much stretching to get there Theory two
is the identity of the antler Queen
since you know season one it's been
theorized by everyone to be Lottie she's
the one that sees Visions has you know
is a little bit kooky and uh it's been
revealed that her entire Wellness
retreat has been modeled after the
Wilderness setting and even has a giant
symbol carved into the ground it's it's
pretty obvious right and not not really
because uh it's all been a clever red
herring as the real antler Queen is
actually Shauna Shauna has always seemed
to be the character at the middle of
this story a leader without knowing it
and now that she's lost her baby the
Wilderness is going to grasp onto this
anger along with her sacrifice of the
baby therefore allowing her to tap into
the wilderness's powers plus all of this
would explain her completely unhinged
behavior in present day and why when she
held up The Chop Shop dude she actually
was enjoying it like she wanted to go
through with it it was reminding her of
the power influence and fear she
presented in the wilderness that has
been dormant for 25 years Shauna is the
antler queen baby and I'm betting that
the seventh member beneath the robes
that started season one is going to be
Aquila I know that she's been teased to
be on the chopping block with her
mentioning wanting to see her young
nephew again and even studying for the
SATs but again all of this has been a
complete misdirect it would also explain
why this character was recast from
season one bringing someone on board
with a little bit more screen time and
experience so I'm saying that the very
last episode of season two is going to
be a big reveal that an adult Aquila is
still alive and well and out there much
like the mic drop reveal of Lottie at
the end of season one and if that's the
case we now have all of our hooded
ritualists identified and uh you know
everyone else in the group they're gonna
be food for the group also no doubt the
opening ritual pit Girl scene is going
to actually be taking place during the
second winter rather than the current
Wilderness time of the first winter so
yeah there's there's gonna be a lot of
waiting for this actual pit girl reveal
and sequence but uh this is what I think
is gonna happen anyway that is episode 7
of season two at this point we are fully
fueling up this season and about to drop
a meant toes into a vat of Coca-Cola and
I am ready for everything to explode it
feels like something big is about to go
down in these last couple episodes now
unfortunately due to scheduling
conflicts we may not be able to get
around to covering episode eight so if
that's the case oh don't worry we'll
we'll be back for episode nine just just
you wait but yeah uh uh what did you
think of episode seven are all of the
yellow jackets back together meaning
some Supernatural Shenanigans are about
to go down and what other outlandish
theories do you have going into these
final two episodes of season two and
I'll let you know we're currently
running the competition giving away
three steelbook copies of Ant-Man
quantumania on the 15th of May and all
you got to do to get a chance of winning
this is like this video subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment down
below with your thoughts of
Yellowjackets episode 7. we pick the
comments at random at the end of every
single month and the winners of last
month on screen right now message us on
Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch be sure to check
out some of our other great videos over
there good just just click one they're
great click one but with all of that out
of the way thank you so much for your
constant support I've been Jared I'll
see in the next one take care and peace